and with that I'd sort of like to tell
you about some of this idea from my work
which is on capturing human behavior and
language for interactive systems so as
we all know computers are more and more
integrated into society into our lives
yet they still don't understand many of
the basic human actions that surround
them so in this talk I'd like to explore
how we can teach computers to understand
much more of this human context and also
what new kinds of interactions we can
enable as a result so and if you think
about it this is really a key component
of many of these core ideas we've had in
human-computer interaction for example
here's Mark Weiser the founder of
ubiquitous computing and when Mark was
first motivating this idea he gives this
example of a smart home that knows you
might want to drink coffee after you
wake up now it's been decades since Mark
first introduced this idea but how close
are we really to systems that understand
these kinds of relationships today for
example you know take an activity like
packing now personally you know whenever
I'm going on a trip I always forget to
bring my melatonin so I would love to be
able to tell a system hey when I'm
packing remind me to bring my route
melatonin but for this to work a system
has to be able to really understand what
packing is and be able to identify it
similarly there's many situations that
are more the inverse of this situations
for example what you don't want to be
interrupted by text messages or other
kinds of notifications for example if
you're talking on the phone now on the
other hand there plenty of situations
where this would be totally ok for
example if you're sitting on the couch
or taking your dog on a walk and so sort
of broadly by understanding the kind of
human context that surrounds us
interactive systems can start to make
decisions that are more reasonable or
not reasonable similarly if we look at
you know stuff in recent science fiction
or maybe the kind of stuff envisioned by
Hollywood again we see systems that do
things like play you upbeat music when
you're sad or warn you when you're
leaving your home without your wallet
and these systems are all very it's all
understanding human behavior in a much
broader sense then systems tend to do
today so today we have these systems
that do a really good job of
understanding facts about the world we
have these massively crowd-sourced
knowledge bases systems like concept net
that could tell us relationships like
water is a liquid we also have these
really great machine learning models
techniques like semantic parsing which
can learn from large data to answer
questions like who's the president dr.
Barack Obama but if we think about these
motivating questions things like
understanding what happens after we wake
up or the fact that we're in a meeting
maybe means we're busy and so we want to
ignore a phone call systems just don't
tend to capture these kinds of
relationships today so what I'd like to
suggest in this talk is that to really
make progress on these visions proposed
by wiser and others what we need are
systems that much more deeply understand
people systems that really capture the
breath of human experience so just to
make this design goal a bit more
explicit what I'm really talking about
here are systems that capture an
enormous number of human activities so
there are thousands of activities that
occur in daily life things like waking
up drinking coffee using a computer
going running imagine anything you do in
a course of a day we want systems that
understand each of those things and it's
important to note here that this is kind
of broadening out the reach of existing
work for example in context we're
computing where people do a good job of
modeling a handful of activities or
similarly work that looks at modeling a
large number of activities but within a
narrow domain for example modeling
sequences of commands in Photoshop to
predict what kind of command someone
might want to execute next so we want to
sort of expand these ideas to encompass
the full breadth of human life now the
obvious challenge you run into here
those you know where does this
information come from
how do we capture these thousands of
human behaviors in the relationships
between them and then how do we model
those for use in our active systems so
let's call that first challenge the sort
of system model and let's even say we
can make progress on that challenge
there's still a second challenge I want
to motivate today and to do this I'd
like to sort of step back and sort of
give a bigger picture of how users
interact with systems so you have a
system and you have an API or a kind of
interface that that system presents but
just as critically you have this idea of
a user model or how our user
conceptualizes interactions with a
system and what's really important here
is that when there's a mismatch between
how a user understands a system and how
a system actually works you can often
run into these big problems so it's not
just enough to be able to capture and
model this kind of information we also
have to focus on how people can use it
and how we can make these models
interpretable to the users and system
designers you might want to make use of
them so in the second part of the talk
I'm going to
explore this more through how we can
allow computational social scientists
this particular subgroup of users to
apply these kinds of models to enable
new kinds of text analysis so that
brings me to the outline of the talk in
the first part of the talk I'll sort of
talk about the system auger which mines
these thousands of behaviors in human
life the relationships between these
behaviors and exposes them to
interactive systems and then in the
second part of the talk I'll focus on
more how people can use and interpret
these models and in particular how
computational social scientists can use
these models to enable new kinds of text
analysis so with that let's move into
auger and sort of just to provide a kind
of baseline for the kinds of predictions
we want to make here here's you know an
example of a piece of context that a
interactive system might want to act
upon for example Facebook it might
benefit from knowing that if you're
around Facebook you might do something
like getting a message or opening or
closing your laptop similarly if you're
around if you're if it knows you're
taking a shower maybe it can then
predict that you want to change your
clothes or brush your teeth or if you've
just ordered coffee maybe it should be
able to predict that maybe you're gonna
take a sip of the coffee or you're gonna
pay for the coffee or if you're around a
stove a pot and a spoon maybe you're
gonna do something like cook or stir the
pot so these are kind of baseline of the
kind of information we want to capture
in the system but again we're left with
this question which is just you know how
do we actually capture this information
we can't just sort of manually sit down
and encode these thousands of behaviors
into the system much less the
interactions between them so we need
some kind of data from which we can mine
these things but what does that data
actually look like well what you might
want or probably don't want is this sort
of dystopian world where cameras are
monitoring everyone 24/7 you can trace
all these user activities right well not
a data set we have also probably not a
data set we want alternatively you could
you know look at stuff like social media
a different kind of dystopia sometimes
you know people post things there all
the time things like I'm running a
marathon you know I'm getting into a new
relationship but these things just don't
quite occur at like right the quite the
right level of abstraction so for
example people don't post things like
you know I'm typing on my keyboard then
I'm standing up then I'm walking to my
window right we don't get this sort of
prosaic or mundane information about the
glue of human life so really the
fundamental idea in this work is what
we use fiction to model this idea of
human behavior what if we use fiction to
capture these many relationships between
human activities and the context that
surrounds them
so fiction has these really two great
advantages first it's built on narrative
so characters do things to interact in
the world and there's a particular
ordering or Association of these things
that they do and the second advantage is
that it has this really rich set of
scene context so there are many places
objects even adjectives that surround
characters when they're taking certain
kinds of actions and we can kind of
combine this together to build these
broad models of human life so we want to
use fiction but what specific data are
we actually interested in here well the
data we used was a specific data from
the Wattpad writing community and the
main property of this data is that it's
modern fiction so these are stories set
in the modern world they're not sort of
like in fantasy places on spaceships
right we want to be able to model things
that people are doing in the world so we
want sort of fiction set in the present
day and similarly this is a very large
corpus more than 2 billion words and as
you can imagine when you want to do this
sort of broad data mining a lot of data
helps you quite a lot here so just to
kind of motivate how this technique
button technique might work I'm going to
give you a simple sentence so he walked
to the bookshelf picked up his favorite
book and started to read and even in
this simple sentence we can start to see
you know how you can build associations
between activities so for example you
know picking up a book is perhaps
associated with reading and similarly we
can see how you know context terms are
surrounded by these activities so
perhaps around a bookshelf you're gonna
do things like you know picking up a
book or reading and so we can combine
you know this insight together to create
what's called the augur knowledge base
so the first thing in here is you know
obviously this idea of human activities
so what do we mean by this well
literally a thing that a person does so
a verb phrase with a human subject so we
can extract these things through subject
verb object parses your drop articles
and modifiers lemma ties these things to
collapse the vocabulary and we end up
with more than 50,000 of them things
like opening a refrigerator or turning
off the lights or going to the gym and
then the second thing in the knowledge
base is this idea of context or this
idea of objects locations and adjectives
that surround characters when they're
taking certain kinds of actions so here
we have more than 10,000 of these in the
knowledge base as well these are things
like beaches shirts
cars or houses and so we put these two
things together to enable these two main
api's the first is an API that takes a
set of scene context and predicts an
activity so for example given context
like plate fork and table I may predict
an activity like eating and the second
thing is an act as an API that takes one
activity or a set of activities and then
predicts an Associated activity so for
example associated with ordering and
eating we might have an activity like
paying so that's how the knowledgebase
looks but how do we actually get here
how do you actually model the fiction to
create these kinds of api's well so
here's the pipeline what happens is we
start with a fiction we run it through
the parsing step so we extract these
subject-verb-object parses these pieces
of context we then pass these to our
neural network where the ideas we're
trying to predict relationships between
words in a sliding window and I'll say
more about that in a bit we can use this
neural network to then build a vector
space which gives us a representation of
these high-level activities as well as
the context terms and then we can query
that vector space to enable the two
api's that I just talked about
so this neural network what is this
thing actually doing well again the
high-level idea here is we want to
predict words within a sliding window to
build a representation of activities and
the context words so effectively by
having neural networks make these
predictions we build up a sort of
meaning a representation in the hidden
layer of the network that provides a
vector space representation so if you've
seen models like the continuous skip
Graham model more commonly known as word
Tyvek this is a very similar idea but
we're extending this to operate on the
high-level idea of activities as well as
the low-level idea of words or context
so just to be very concrete about how
this works here's the set of sequence
data and the kind of prediction tasks
that we give to the network so we have a
window it slides over the data we have a
target word for example you're cold and
then we try to predict you know other
words or activities within the window
things like day and walk home and then
we slide the window down create a new
target word now we our target as day and
we predict cold walk home and eat lunch
we slide it down again we make these
thousands even millions of predictions
all over the data to build up this sort
of hidden layer representation and again
the high-level idea here is we're
building up a representation of these
activities in context that we can then
use for these downstream
berries so here's concretely what the
network looks like again is probably
familiar to you if you've seen these
kinds of networks before again what
we're doing here is we're extending the
input vocabulary to contain the high
level activities as well as the context
words again then that's past the hidden
layer we make these predictions about
other words in the space and then we
sort of build up a meaning over time and
so what we can do then is you know take
this meaning that we've built up in the
hidden layer and convert that into a
representation for everything in the
vocabulary so effectively we have a
matrix here where we can index in on
that matrix to get a representation for
different words and activities in the
space so for example an activity like
eat home or eat food would then you know
have a vector representation that we
could use for these downstream tasks and
so a vector space is useful here because
it provides this sort of natural sense
of similarity or relationship between
different things in the space so for
example if I have a vector space then I
inject a piece of context context like
lunch I can just look in that space and
see what kinds of activities are closer
in the space and what activities are
further away so for example activities
like eating and cooking might be closer
in the space whereas activities like
hailing a cab or driving or further away
in this space and we can formalize this
through measures like cosine similarity
distance measures over vectors which you
know give you things like you know table
and eating has relatively high cosine
similarity table and pet dog would have
relatively lower cosine similarity and
the other nice property here is that we
can query on multiple examples through
this nice property of vector addition
right so if we want to combine multiple
pieces of context for a query we just
sum of those vectors together run that
against all the other activities in the
space using cosine similarity then can
compute a ranked list of the associated
activities so this gives us stuff like
this if we're around a plate a steak in
a fork we can make predictions like
maybe we're filling the plate or we're
eating food if we round a bench maybe
we're making predictions like sitting if
we're around or if we give an activity
like waking up maybe we want breakfast
or we want to check the clock if we're
taking a selfie maybe we want to take or
upload a photo so that's the kind of
prediction that we can enable through
this system but what kinds of
applications can we actually build on
top of those models so I mentioned
earlier in the talk this idea of sort of
a phone that's reacting to the context
around you so can all go do something
like this
well we can take an activity like get
call and look at the answer set returned
by the vector space we see things like
answering call calling back ignoring the
call and now we can start to combine
this with other kinds of context and see
how these sort of relationships change
so when we add in something like cursing
to this vector we now see that ignore
call moves higher in the list than
answer call we also see new things enter
the list things like throwing phone
which reflects the dramatic bias of
fiction which will say a little bit more
about in a second but also are in their
own right useful things that interactive
systems might be able to leverage
similarly at the beginning I gave this
example packing right so it can all go
do something like this
well given context like for example a
shirt shoes in a suitcase we can look at
sort of what are associated activities
in the space and we see things yes in
fact like packing also like wearing
clothes or putting on shoes so again we
didn't have to sort of manually
predefined all of the different things
that might lead to packing the sort of
natural relationships that fall out of
this vector space sort of give us that
information for free again maybe there's
a another example where I've been
spending too much money recently and I
want a notification a sort of text
message whenever Auger thinks I'm going
to spend more money sort of to prevent
me from doing this so there's a number
of activities that might result in a
future activity or an associated
activity of spending money for example
entering the store perhaps you're likely
to pay for something but it's really
quite a diverse set of activities here
so for example when you enter or call a
taxi this is also an activity that's
likely to result in a pay action and
again we didn't have to sort of pre
encode all of these different activities
that might be associated with paying we
sort of get these out of the
relationships in the space okay so
that's a kind of illustration of what
kinds of applications we can build but
how do we actually embed this system
into the world right how do we actually
get this signal about sort of you know
what are these pieces of context that
surround us so to do this we can add a
new layer to the pipeline a sort of
computer vision layer taking
off-the-shelf computer vision processing
some images to produce context terms
then pass those terms to the API to make
these activity predictions which then
these interactive systems can begin to
react to so the basic way this works is
you have a picture you take some CV
context out of the picture so your
computer vision tells us like this
picture has people mountain tree and
backpack we can then pass these to the
augur API and we see things like hike
or reaching the top or another picture
of beach scene we can pass this to auger
and we see things like laying a towel or
diving and we actually built this out
into what we call the dynamic music
player so we took a Google glass I'll
sort of had it take continuous pictures
over the scene of those pictures past
the auger API identified sort of
activities that it could and then pass
those back to play different kinds of
music so we were looking at seven
activities in particular walking working
sitting eating driving buying and
reading and we just sort of wanted to
see you know how well could the system
do in practice that identifying this
sort of basic set of activities you get
given the context that we were able to
get get from these images and so just to
give you a few examples of the frames
here here's a picture in the car right
so of course we can predict that were
driving and here's a picture in the
library and of course we can predict
that we are reading and so we computed a
precision and recall across all the
activities in the system over these
frames and so what we found was that
recall tended to be quite a bit higher
than precision so the system was
relatively good at identifying an
activity when it was happening but there
were quite a few more false positives
right which lower the precision a little
bit so what this sort of suggests is
that when you're designing for these
kinds of applications you should be
focused on more recall oriented systems
or at least systems that can tolerate
this low precision so for example if I'm
building a food diary that takes a
picture automatically when it thinks I'm
eating you know false positive there
isn't going to be the end of the world
on the other hand if I'm having a
self-driving car react to some positive
prediction you know that could be a very
big deal right so these are the kind of
designs constraints to be keeping in
mind here so it's sort of stepping back
a bit what I want to sort of really get
across here is that this is opening a
new design space which gives you these
sort of two main abilities the first is
the ability to react to current
activities right so this is expressed
through things like well if I'm eating
food I want you to take a picture for my
food diary or combining different sort
of present signals things like oh if I'm
getting a call and then I'm cursing
maybe we're gonna silence the phone or
if I'm cooking bringing up a recipe
application and then the second thing we
get here is this idea of proactivity on
future or associated activities so for
example if I'm calling a suitcase and
Aughra can say that while getting a
suitcase is something that's likely to
follow that and the
we have another piece of signal that
says the suitcase is not with me maybe
we can say oh you don't have your
suitcase give you a warning about that
or if I'm entering a store maybe we can
predict that I'm going to pay for
something and so it's send me a text
message that gives me my bank balance
information or if I'm buying food maybe
we can predict that I'm going to cook
later and so sort of remind me what
ingredients that I need so we sort of
open up these two broad design spaces
here so with that I'd like to move a
little bit into more of a formal
technical evaluation because with these
kinds of systems you can sort of
evaluate and see you know how these
applications work but it's also
important to have benchmarks that you
can use to continue to improve these
models we serve benchmarks that other
people can use to build similar models
and improve on what you're doing so in
this case what we're gonna do is
crowdsource a sort of gold standard set
of labels basically replicating the
kinds of tasks we're asking this if the
system to do in practice so here for
example giving you know proud workers a
set of context terms and then asking
them to predict what kinds of activities
will occur around those terms but if we
can do the same thing for giving the
crowd workers activities and then asking
them to tell you what activities are
gonna be associated with those
activities and so what we get here is
the sort of data set that looks
something like this here's a few
examples if you give a crowd something
like clock countdown in television
they'll tell you well things like
watching TV you're celebrating or
checking the time those are the kinds of
things that will happen or if you ask
the crowd what happens you know with
opening a folder and reading a paper
they'll say oh maybe closing the folder
or organizing or starting work and now
that we have this sort of ground truth
data set we can go through and actually
see you know how well does the model do
it distinguishing these things from the
other stuff in the space so we can
compute some numbers here using a UC or
AU ROC the nice thing about this is that
sort of aggregates over all the
different to positive rates we have a
baseline rate of 50 percent so if the
model is not doing anything it's going
to be a 50 percent we also included a
sort of you know baseline naive model
based on co-occurrence accounts so you
know what happens if you just sort of
take activity context relationships and
build a sort of naive vector space using
co-occurrence statistics you can see
that does a little bit better than the
random model but not as good as a neural
network you can also see that sort of as
we increase the size of the hidden layer
in the neural network the performance
goes up but it's sort of asymptotes over
time
I think it's important to point out here
that you know while these numbers look
relatively good they don't represent
performance on a real-world task these
are simply benchmarks that you can use
to sort of you know evaluate and
continue to improve the models here so
the second kind of formal evaluation we
really wanted to do was attack this idea
more directly of dramatic bias and
fiction right so in fiction if I enter a
room it's perhaps far more likely I'm
going to go and punch someone than it is
in reality right so you know to what
extent is as a problem in our data and
sort of how can we start to evaluate
this so the basic idea we had was that
again we can use crowdsourcing to
construct a data set of a human prior
over you know what's likely to happen
around different kinds of contexts or
different kinds of objects so we can ask
people effectively you know if we have a
chair you know what are what is the
likelihood that this set of activities
is going to happen around a chair is it
more likely that I'm going to sit in the
chair that I'm gonna throw the chair
that I'm going to pull up the chair
right so we can sort of get the sort of
distribution of likelihood over these
related activities and then what we can
do is compare the distribution produced
by the system to the distribution
produced by the humans and sort of see
what kinds of bias crop up so when we do
this in practice we do see a significant
difference between the system and the
people it wasn't quite as big as we were
expecting and actually when we sort of
dig into it a little bit we see that the
vast majority of this difference comes
from these super mundane activities like
seeing so the system says you're far
more likely to see a chair so people see
a chair in fiction all of the time
whereas if you ask Youmans you know are
you more likely to see a chair or sit in
a chair they'll actually say they're
more likely to sit in a chair all right
so there's sort of an ambiguity here or
perhaps a human bias that's kind of
affecting this a little bit as well of
course we did also see some of this
dramatic bias that we were expecting and
in here it sort of took more often the
romantic turn so again because this is
modern fiction sort of set in the modern
world and we filtered for that a lot of
these stories were romance stories right
so if you have these kinds of
interpersonal interactions these are far
more likely to result in things like
kissing then you might have in the real
world
okay so with that I really just sort of
hope I've sort of convinced you that
text fiction really can teach computers
the surprisingly broad and accurate
models of the world right so these
models aren't necessarily going to be
driving your self-driving car tomorrow
but they do provide useful priors that
we can use to start build
new kinds of interactive systems and so
with that I'd like to move into the
second part of my talk so in this part
of the talk I'm gonna focus a little bit
more on this idea of interpretability or
or usability of these models and how
other kinds of groups can use and
introspect them and in particular how we
can use similar kinds of models to allow
computational social scientists to do
new kinds of text analysis and this is a
system called empath
so as I've kind of just been talking
about today we have all of these really
powerful language models we have these
word embeddings they give you this like
really rich idea of connotation we have
these great supervised learning models
things like convolutional neural
networks recurrent neural networks we
have this great unsupervised topic
modeling and then sort of on the other
side of the world we have all this stuff
that's going on in computational social
science so people are doing things like
you tracking the spread of emotions on
Facebook looking at sort of you know
what words indicate on lying or telling
the truth
even trying to figure out what words
indicate that I'm gonna betray you and
if you think about it you might expect
that people are often leveraging these
powerful language models to engage in
this kind of work but if you go out and
look in the space I think you'll find
that this is you know surprisingly often
not the case and the reason I'd like to
give in this talk for this is that
computational social sciences strongly
value interpretability in their models
right so you know when they report in
effect they want to be able to very
specifically point to where did that
effect come from and so what this means
is that people very often use what are
called rule-based models models that
have a small number of very easily
interpretable rules so things like
decision trees or inclusion exclusion
properties for words and again the goal
here is that you know people are able to
inspect these models with very limited
technical sophistication so a very
common kind of model that people use
here is what's called a lexicon a
category that sort of is represented by
a list of words so for example if I want
to measure anger and text I have this
word list contains words like scream war
mad and so on and I sort of use that
word list to analyze the text across the
categories I'm interested in so there
have been many of these tools created
over the years very extensively
validated probably the most popular of
which is called Luke linguistic in
Korean word count this thing has been
used for hundreds or thousands of
studies been very impactful and again
how these things work is you have a
piece of text you walk over the text
you count the words that fall into the
given category that you're interested in
you can then take normalized counts over
those categories and then compare those
counts across populations of documents
to compute some kind of statistic so if
you just sort of think about this you
start to run into some obvious questions
right so the first question is well what
about breath right what if I want to
analyze a category that doesn't exist in
any lexicon today for example a category
like violence or like social media right
these are things that don't exist in
Luke similarly what about words that
don't exist in these categories right so
these categories are updated very
infrequently once every few years
few years or so and so you end up with
you know categoric Bitcoin not appearing
in Luke's money category for example so
the idea that we're presenting in this
work is that we'd like to take this very
powerful and useful conceptual model
provided by lexicons that computational
social scientists use today and combine
this with the power of these more
sophisticated language models
I didn't sort of get the best of both of
this both of these techniques so what we
did was we came up with a tool called
empath and what this tool allows you to
do is generate new categories from a set
of seed words so for example if I have
if I want to analyze categories called
social media I can choose to seed words
that sort of best approximate that
category words like for example Twitter
and Facebook I can then use empath to
generate a set of words basically a word
list that I can use to analyze that
category and then go and apply that
category to the text and again we can
use the sort of standard ideas from
cosine similarity and other kinds of
natural language processing to create
these kinds of word lists and what we
can also do because it's so easy to
generate these things is create a much
broader set of hundreds of predefined
categories that people can use for their
analyses today so these are categories
like technology violence government
strength all of these things that don't
exist in lexicons like Luke and again
the idea here is that we want to
maintain interpretability while
increasing the breadth in terms of the
number of categories that people are
able to analyze as well as the
flexibility basically allowing people to
generate these new categories on demand
now the question you run into though is
well how well do these language models
actually replicate the psychrometric Lee
validated word lists right in some cases
literally teams of psychologists sat
down in a room and created these word
lists so how well can these machine
generated lexicons
actually performing comparison to these
things well the first thing you want to
do in this case is kind of create a
baseline or a benchmark and so what you
can do is you can take correlations
between the signals reported by existing
similar human generated lexicons so I've
already talked about Luke there's other
lexicons like the general and fire and
like emo Lex we can compare the signals
reported by similar categories in each
of these tools and get Pearson
correlations and what we end up with
this stuff like you know point eight
nine point eight seven and now what we
can do is generate our machine generated
lexicons and see how well those compare
in comparison so here the actual
processes you have a set of training
text you choose some words on that
training text that best approximate the
category you're interested in then you
apply that category on the held-out test
text and then you compute a Pearson
correlation over all these counts that
you produce and so what we end up with
here is that we have a correlation on
average of 0.9 over the categories we
compare it against with Luke and this
compares very favorably against the sort
of Pearson correlations taken between
the existing human generated lexicons so
we can actually even push this one step
further and look at can we actually
replicate some existing high-impact work
in the space so for example in 2011
Golder and macy published this study
looking at mood on twitter over time of
day and so what they found was sort of
as the day goes on you have this sort of
increase in negative effect on Twitter
where you have this sort of peak and
decline of the positive effect and so
what we're able to do is sort of you
know replicate those signals using the
Luke tool and then show how the
categories and empath also replicate
nearly exactly the same signals again
with this sort of very high correlation
and so the take-home point here is that
really these unsupervised language
models really can capture many of the
same signals as the psychometrically
validated word lists right these models
capture many of the dimensions that
humans are using when they construct
these word lists in the first place so I
mentioned that empath has a number of
other predefined categories so how do we
actually get these things well the basic
idea was we bootstrap them off of
relationships and existing knowledge
basis so I mentioned concept not earlier
in the talk this thing contains element
of relationships like shirts and hats or
elements of clothing we can effectively
look at those relationships and use them
to bootstrap a new set of categories in
empath and so what we end up with is you
know pretty large set of categories
things like journalism Envy
music communication programming even
stuff like hipster and here's what some
of these look like so for violence you
have injure fight bleed hipster iconic
stylish retro technology robot browser
binary pretty diverse set of stuff and
so what we did was we took this and we
sort of put it out in various different
ways we have a website where people can
go and generate new categories to use
for their text analysis we also have a
Python tool that people can download and
use to either generate new categories or
analyze text and this has been picked up
and used by a number of external
researchers so people have used it for
example to characterize hateful speech
on Twitter to look at linguistic trends
as communities grow over time or even to
look at linguistic differences between
effective and non effective team
structures and this work has been
published in pretty respectable venues
venues like IC WSM or chi oh sorry ok
yeah guy it also it's in use by Facebook
data science so now actually what I want
to do is show you how you can use this
tool to extend some existing work in
computational social science well I'm
actually going to kill two birds with
one stone here and show you this demo
through another tool that I've just
published in Chi 2018 called iris this
is a conversational agent that allows
you to do data science basically sort of
mixed conversation and programming
interface and the main purpose for this
is that it gives me a very quick way to
go through this analysis and sort of
show you the core of what empath is
doing so the first thing I'm going to do
is load up some data into the system so
you can see I start typing a command
into the system I get some query
responses back are the thing on the far
left is the thing that's actually gonna
execute so I'm gonna choose a file and
again what the file I'm looking at here
is some original data collected by odd
at all and what they were looking at was
some tripadvisor data some hotel review
data and what they were trying to do was
distinguish between you know this and
fake reviews so they crowdsource a bunch
of fake reviews on Mechanical Turk and
then they looked for linguistic signals
that would differentiate these real
reviews from the fake reviews so here
you can see the data set has you know a
review column this is the text it has
you know a truth value 0 is true it has
a sentiment which we're not going to use
so the first thing I want to do
here's just sort of show you kind of the
breadth of the kinds of signals that
empath can capture so I'm just gonna
type in empath so we're gonna analyze
the hotel data frame for empath it's
gonna ask me what column I want to
analyze I'm gonna click on the review
column it's gonna ask me if I want to
aggregate the counts in this case yes I
just sort of want to overall count and
so I get these these categories coming
back but what I think we can do better
here I'm gonna actually just plot these
things to give you a better sense of it
so I reference the previous thing that
we just did with that keyword now I'm
gonna choose a column with the labels
and with values and we'll look at just
20 categories so here you can see things
like vacation traveling tourism things
like air travel business right this is
more or less what you the kind of stuff
you'd expect in a hotel review dataset
so you know the original work was really
able to quite successfully distinguish
the truth or reviews from the fake
reviews but something they weren't
actually able to do was test this
hypothesis from the other psychology
literature that they had some evidence
for this was this idea that Liars use
less concrete or spatial language so
what we can do is actually generate a
new empath category to capture that
dimension of language and then analyze
these reviews to see whether we can pull
up any signal from that category so here
I'm going to generate a new empath
category and I'm just going to call it
shape size since that's kind of what
we're going for
and I want these sort of concrete
spatial terms so I'm going to enter a
few here so big small and circular these
kind of describes shape orientation of
things in a room but actually like to
make this interactive would anyone like
to suggest a new term so we can do some
actual novel replication long
okay I'm not just a sample of the kinds
of things that gets okay interesting
very interesting we'll see if that one
replicates we'll see if that replicates
okay so so now what we're gonna do is
apply this to the to the data frame so
what I'm doing is applying this category
to the data frame
this time we do not want to aggregate
the counts so you can see now we have
these new counts for each of the
documents here now I'm going to sort of
combine this with the existing data
frame that we have so I'm going to
combine the columns
they've got anyone use that that keyword
and so now at the end here you can see
we've just appended the shape size on
and so now what we want to do is break
these into the two populations the fake
reviews and the real reviews so I'm
gonna do a filter operation but first
I'm gonna save the data and so I want to
filter the data I want to filter by the
truth column I want that column to be
equal to zero so you can see we selected
those so I'll save that then I'll do
that again
and you can see we have now the truth
one okay so now we have these two
populations and we just want to do a
t-test over the the statistics we've
already collected so here let's just
type in t-test let's just do a students
t-test just for simplicity and we're
going to compare the truthful reviews
and again select the shape size column
there and we're going to look at the
fake reviews in comparison and so yes
even in that case we still do get a
significant result where the truthful
reviews do have more of this concrete
and spatial language so we've actually
done some new computational social
science okay so I just sort of like to
take a step back and kind of go over a
few other research areas that I'm
involved in and what some interesting
questions here are going for words so I
just talked to you about these two
systems the first auger sort of mines
these thousands of human activities the
relationships between them exposes that
data to interactive systems the second
system Ampath is sort of looking at more
from the standpoint of an usability and
interpret interpret ability how people
can leverage these models for new kinds
of text analysis but these systems
really represent a subset of a much
broader areas of work that sorry much
broader set of areas that I do work in
areas like computational social science
for example so not only can we build
systems like empaths to enable this kind
of work we can actually do some of this
work for example looking at signals of
gender bias and social media similarly
in the space of data mining we can apply
techniques similar to the kind of
technique we applied with auger to other
domains for example the domain of open
source code looking at patterns there
and on the area of programming again
through interfaces like the iris demo
that I just showed you we can think
about what are some fundamentally new
ways that we can engage with programming
languages so I just want to step through
a few of these areas now and kind of you
know hint at what I think some important
questions are going forward so in this
area of computational social science
much of my work has focused on this idea
of you know sort of finding signal and
text
so we've done work for example like
finding measuring the trends in public
perception of AI over the decades this
was work with Eric Orbitz who by the way
is joining us remotely you can't see him
that he's here on skype also similarly
looking at signals and gender bias and
social media basically trying to
understand you know when this happens
who's responsible for it why it happens
and similarly looking at signals of a
sort of dogmatism or this idea of
polarized opinion or argument in social
media for example signals of this kind
of opinion on reddit and so just to give
you an example of you know how some of
this stuff works here's a graph from the
trends in the public perception of AI
paper so you can see that in 2009 we
just had this huge uplift and discussion
around AI on the y-axis here we have the
sort of percentage of all articles in
the news that are discussing AI but
really the main point of this work was
to engage with a much more nuanced set
of signals and look at how these signals
tracked over the decades so for example
you know this idea of ethical concerns
for AI or that AI is going to be making
decisions for us that we might be
concerned about this is an idea that's
been sort of increasing in the public
consciousness in recent years or
similarly this idea the losing control
of AI like maybe you've heard of Elon
Musk this idea of summoning the demon
right that we're going to lose control
of these technologies this is also an
idea that's been sort of increasing in
recent years where is this idea that's
more like the utopian economic vision
that AI is going to have this great
impact on our work lives this is
something that's been more stagnant to
potentially decreasing over time and
again the high-level idea here is that
you know as practitioners it's good to
be aware of these signals and how the
public is viewing our work and sort of
in the worst case you can sort of
hopefully avoid things like AI winters
and sort of stepping back more broadly
from this I think it kind of illustrates
you know a bigger question which is just
how could we can learn from these large
communities to make better decisions you
know potentially as a society to drive
public policy but also to build new
kinds of interfaces so for example if we
can detect signals like gender bias in
an online community can we start to use
those kinds of you know tools to build
interfaces that start to shape how that
signal flows in the online community
basically can we start to build
interfaces that shape these communities
in the way that we want them to be now
the next area I want to talk about is
shifting gears a bit towards more this
idea of programming tools and how we can
empower people to do new kinds of work
and
better leverage programming languages so
in this area I've drawn a lot on the
same kinds of data mining I've just
showed you an auger for example in codex
looking at statistical patterns in large
datasets of open source code basically
finding code commonality patterns that
might indicate a bug or even finding
patterns and then sort of farming those
out to expert crowd workers to enable
this idea of automatic documentation we
can kind of shift that idea a little bit
- dynamic runtime traces through
projects like meta basically trying to
imagine you know what happens when a
programming language is inspecting and
aware of everything a user is doing with
it or everything every user is doing
with it basically tracking runtime data
through functions allowing you to do
things like for example say hey you're
using a function that's very similar to
this other function someone else is
using
but his function is better or even you
know in a more advanced case when your
function fails hot swapping it in with a
different function made by someone else
in the community to enable this idea of
automatic runtime patching and similarly
as I showed you with iris this idea of
you know how can we think about new ways
of interacting with programming
languages so I just wanted to spend a
little bit more time on iris and again
as you saw in the demo that iris is a
conversational agent that enables this
sort of complex data analysis but it's
really driven by you know this these two
high-level ideas the first is this idea
from sociolinguistic theory of
conversation analysis that looks at how
humans communicate through back and
forth conversation to express complex
ideas and then connecting that with a
programming model right these
programming models that enable you know
so much of the kind of complex analysis
that we want to do today and making
these things basically enable these
open-ended command combinations that
effectively allow users to build up a
STS over time as a representation of the
conversation State so here I think
there's quite a lot of more work to do
on this broader idea of tightening
feedback loops between users and
programming languages so for example
once more users and data are flowing
through iris can we leverage something
like reinforcement learning to make much
more to give much more sophisticated
guidance as people are working through
these tasks similarly can we take
techniques like programming by example
to Rhian capsulate a set of steps that
one user just executed as a new
standalone function that someone else in
the community can use and benefit from
so there's quite a lot of future work to
go on here now there's one final area
that I want to talk about we just
drawing on this no similar idea of a
user model but with more of a focus on
you know what we can think of as
decentralized systems so if you go out
in the sort of look at you know how
users are interacting with decentralized
systems today for example blockchain
applications talk to people in this
space most users users have absolutely
no idea what's going on underneath the
hood of these applications their mental
models are just not designed for how
these applications actually work
similarly if you talk to programmers
there's a huge set of skills that they
need to understand to be able to program
and develop these applications skills
like understanding how a signal sir
propagates through a distributed network
or the various constraints provided
again if we're talking about blockchain
applications of smart contracts right or
public key cryptography huge set of
things here and there's a big
opportunity to provide abstractions in
dsls that sort of bridge this sort of
abstraction or this gap for these
programmers who don't necessarily
understand these ideas so much of the
work I've done in this space so far has
actually focused more on community
development
so with others I co-founded this
organization called coz a decentralized
open-source community that is building
these blockchain applications and so
we've actually had quite a lot of
success here at developing applications
with collectively hundreds of thousands
of users and we did this through really
making open calls to the open source
community which have resulted in
thousands of contributions from hundreds
of people across the world these those
contributions have allowed us to do
things like develop an asset management
platform that is responsible for more
than 10 million dollars in transaction
volume every day or build a Python DSL
for smart contracts that has created
bodies created these smart contracts
worth collectively hundreds of millions
of dollars so what I really want to
point out here is that you know this
sort of platform provides a huge set of
data both about how users are
interacting with these applications and
also how programmers want to develop
them that can be a huge resource in
answering these kinds of research
questions going forwards so I'd just
like to close on one final thought which
I think will have quite a lot of impact
in the future so hopefully over the
course of this talk I've convinced you
that we can draw on community data to
empower interfaces but I think it's just
as important if not more important to
think about how we can close that loop
and build interfaces that really in
our communities so one really important
tool we have for this are these
sophisticated machine learning models
but these are things unfortunately
require a lot of data but I actually
think this presents a big opportunity
for us so in the midst of an open source
deployment of iris in partnership with
bioinformaticians at stanford others in
data journalism and the course of this
deployment we hope to collect data from
thousands tens of thousands potentially
even hundreds of thousands of users to
better understand how people work
through these data analysis pipelines
and so what I hope to achieve by this is
this idea of a virtuous cycle where an
interface learns from a community goes
on to empower work in that community
learns from the community and again goes
effectively getting at this idea of
tightening feedback loops between
programmers communities and the programs
that they write so with that I just like
to thank the many mentors and
collaborators that I've had over the
years in particular my advisor Michael
Bernstein it's been really really great
working with you I'd also like to give a
special thanks to my committee so Eric
who's who's on skype eric Horvitz Sean
Fullmer James Landy Manish everyone
thank you so much for being here and for
providing your advice also the many
graduate students who really shaped my
time here at Stanford right like it
wouldn't be the same without you so
thanks so much
and finally the the undergraduate meant
mentees that I've had over the years
whose results have really you know
helped shape some of the work that I
presented today so with that I just like
to thank everyone and open it up for a
discussion
[Applause]
you